It looks like a scene from the Lord of the Rings.
But just 20 miles from Iceland's capital, Reykjavik,...
...it is nature that is forging a new landscape,...
...smoldering, bubbling with fountains of fire.
This drone footage allows us to look right into the eyes of the eruption,...
...a window into the abyss.
Noxious gases don't stop thousands of people trying to get as close as they can.
For some, it is completely breathtaking.
In fact, so many people have come that the civil defense...
...has been brought in and people are being urged to stay back...
...and within designated tourist areas.
Lava is spewing from a 200-meter-long crack...
...that appeared after a series of earthquakes...
...and more openings could still form.
Magma is on the move,...
...but there is no immediate risk to the nearest town about six miles away...
...and the nearby international airport is still open.
The Reykjanes Peninsula erupted last year, too.
That was after centuries of stillness.
Scientists say the earth here is woken up from a deep slumber.
There could be much more of this to come.